so in the outer worlds are given many
different difficulties one of which
being supernova aka survival where you
have to eat sleep and drink like a
normal human but can we beat the outer
world supernova without eating drinking
or sleeping of course the one and only
rule for this is that we must beat the
game without using any drinks food or
sleeping and supernovae so we're
definitely going to be on a tight time
limit just a quick refresh if you don't
know what supernova is basically it is
the highest difficulty in the game and
it is the only difficulty in the game
that if you disable it and you go too
hard you cannot bring it back to
supernova enemies have more health and
deal more damage
you must eat drink and sleep to survive
companions can die permanently crippled
body and limb damage can only be healed
with bed rest weapons and armor work
very poorly at zero durability you could
only fast travel to the ship you can
only sleep inside the ship and you can
only manually save while also inside the
ship and auto-saves do exist but they
are extremely limited also this
technically counts as getting the
supernova achievement so you could kind
of count this as a guide to if you want
to follow along mad credit to the boy
sharo a speed runner for the outer
worlds if it wasn't for one of his
videos I would have definitely not
learned some of these new strats he's
currently the record holder for the Sun
ending any % which is 10 minutes the
supernova ending which is 12 minutes the
Phineas ending at 15 minutes and the
board ending at 16 minutes so he's
beaten this game many a times in a very
quick amount of time
if you want I'll leave his 10 minute
anypercent run the fastest way to beat
the outer worlds as quick as you can
I'll leave that down in the description
and tell him I sent you but for some
useful I wanted to see how long it takes
to die while standing still [ __ ] took
longer than I thought I did I actually
went through like five different Joe Joe
episodes before I started even taking
damage from this it doesn't mean
anything for the run because when you're
sprinting you're wasting a lot more than
just standing still just some nice stats
and also to increase this videos plank
but on to the game for the skills you're
going to be needing below average in
strength dexterity and intelligence and
very high and perception charm and
temperament your skills are going to
to put in stealth and dialogue and your
aptitude is gonna be medical for that
extra bit of healing appearance doesn't
really matter so I made this classy
looking men who from now on will just be
called Jim the very beginning is super
simple of just a running around the
enemies to get to the ship and then
talking to Ada after instead of
confronting the enemies you might want
to run around them and go up on this
hill to avoid any damage to go straight
to Edgewater and then talk to Reid and
ignore Parvati because of this run she's
actually unneeded as sad as that is and
then run right to the lab you can ignore
Adelaide because that's wasted time and
of course we are on a time limit you
could opt to kill some of the robots in
there but running around them while
flicking the levers is the quickest and
easiest way to do this if for some odd
reason you need to reset aggro thanks to
this game's beautiful mechanics all you
have to do is leave the lab and come
back and you could open up some of those
terminals that you couldn't before cuz
you're still in combat you want to
divert the power to the botanical lab as
opposed to Edgewater to save time
running so you because you can't fast
travel if you're a longtime viewer of
the channel you know that I actually
never do this surprisingly this was the
first time I have actually finished a
run where I've diverted the power to a
delay did not read so like I said it's
the first I'm glad I got to share it
with all of you but let's get back to
the video thanks to your beginning stats
and intimidate you could speech check
read so you're not shot on sight grab
the power regulator and fast travel to
the ship and gets a groundbreaker and
probably about two to three minutes like
I said next is Grom breaker and this is
in my opinion an absolute necessity we
have a couple things we need to do here
we need to grab Ellie we need to grab
the defective Moonman head and we gate
and we need to grab down seal first to
get to 'adam seal you need to go to
glide ease office and you need to crouch
in the corner just enough so that you
won't really be caught when you're
trying to open this safe if you have
about 40 to 50 within the sneak treat
you should be able to open this within
seconds and nobody will see you and
you'll feel good glad he might talk to
you once you open it but you can speech
check your way out and grab the seal
immediately so you should have no issue
with that
next is the defective Moon Man helmet
which is behind Martin in the back room
on the top shelf this boosts your
temperament and a little bit of the lie
stat which is absolutely necessary for
the ending then before you leave we need
to talk to Ellie and finish her
recruitment mission which is done by
picking the ID cartridge talking to
Jessie then going back to you Dom
telling him to really
sir and mentioned the seal that you got
him kind of like a hey bud you owe me
kind of message and he'll get the gist
so he'll release Jesse then you can add
Elly to the group and she's needed for
the Y category because the fatigue that
we're gonna be getting from no sleep is
draining it but the time you entered
Byzantium your lockpick should be at 45
minimum so be aware though you might
need to make it a little bit higher
thanks to fatigue kicking in from no
sleep you might need to set that number
higher like 55 in lock pick just to make
sure and then having everything in the
dialogue tree the lie the persuade the
intimidate at 40 just in case and then
the rest can go into the sneak once you
make it to Byzantium talk to Percy and
Sophia to start the first quest this was
where you hunt that woman with Sherman
personally one of my favorite quest
Sherman is besides the companion Sherman
is easily one of my favorite characters
to get the door to her office you need a
45 lockpick which is why you need that
number you could just talk to Sherman
and like speech check them but I just
decide to lockpick anyway you can let
Sherman killer to start no confrontation
between the two of you or you can kill
her it really doesn't matter but I just
did it anyways to not take any damage
and then report back to Sophia and get
your XP afterwards we're gonna do what's
called a pro-gamer move you're gonna
pickpocket Percy right in front of him
to get him to chase us and then sit near
the door and boom you just completed
monarch without actually stepping on the
planet the game doesn't count it but you
could take the necessary steps to do so
the reason why this works is because
Percy is one of the two people in the
game I believe him and minister Clarke
who have the key card to get into this
door so that's why you pickpocket him so
that he chases you and for some odd
reason the game's weird mechanics happen
so that he hits the door and opens it
saving you a bunch of time on monarch
because let's be honest that planet
sucks
we don't care once the store opens you
want to do the normal stuff that you
would do in a normal playthrough where
you go to the computer watch the video
and print that key card to go to the
Ministry of accuracy and morale then you
go from there and head to the
underground lab to avoid dying in this
area because you will die very quickly
you want a pickpocket this specific
guard who has the ID cartridge from the
board inside of him and then stroll over
to the chemical lab and grab whatever
percentage you want and get the [ __ ] out
of there some of the guards may halt you
and ask what's up if your shroud is
depleted so no worries you get three
attempts before they shoot you on sight
the first is a speech check of 20 the
second is
we check up 40 and I believe the third
is a speech check of 60 but if you're at
60 that means you're taking too long and
you didn't need to do any of that that's
why I said to keep it at 40 just in case
once you exit though go to Phineas's lab
and say you have the chemicals the main
quest automatically skips everything
that you're at because technically the
game still thinks that you're still
talking to gladium groundbreaker
it skips everything and automatically
starts you do the hope mission so you're
extremely far into the game input Aida
as you normally would and then go to
that side room once you get to that lock
you're gonna need to get that ID
cartridge to make this room just a
little bit more easier to navigate when
you're in the hope this room isn't
really nothing special walk around the
robots open the terminals go past the
guards you make it to the elevator and
you get to the terminal very simple
stuff tell ADA you're gonna skip the
hope and you drive it into the Sun and
you beat the outer world supernova
without eating drinking or sleeping wait
you wanted the other ending fine instead
of skipping it yourself tell ADA to skip
it for you once you finish that return
to the unreliable for the ending
missions phineas got jumped by the board
because he's a little [ __ ] so you have
to go back to his lab and get his stuff
there about three to four guards in here
all you really have to do is pay
attention to the one that's actually
moving and you can actually walk right
past him and don't even need to crouch
then just walk over to the cyst fig in
the back and grab the keycard open the
panel take the doc module and his gun
and walk right out now you're officially
at the end and good news it gets easier
all you have to do is respect every
single one of your stats and put them
into your lie hopefully with the ability
of Ellie and then the Moon Man helmet
that you're wearing your life should
actually be over a hundred just to
counteract the fatigue and then anything
else can be put in to sneak in
pickpocket whatever you need to do lie
is the most important part if you don't
have any funds so your shrink-ray or the
N ray damage gun that you've just got
from Phineas on his desk both work cuz
you need to 500 bits to do so once you
get to Tartarus you want to bring Ellie
with you who should have about seven to
nine points and live for you and then
the five points from the defective Moon
Man helmet will help you counteract that
fatigue you're gonna be receiving from
no sleep so you should be over a hundred
lie once you get to Tartarus you'll be
stopped by a guard as usual you can
convince him to give you his ID for
seventy lie and then you could sprint
through the entire area going through
all the elevators and lifts without
getting shot and in the meantime let's
read
a bedtime story there once was a story
of a teenager around 19 years of age who
wanted to entertain people for a career
he didn't have many friends in school
but the friends he did have said he was
very funny and entertaining this gave
him lots of confidence in his life and
made him think that maybe it was the
truth maybe he was destined to be funny
so funny in fact that he kept this dumb
bit going this long that the people that
have already watched it by now
have already clicked off the video after
getting to Sofia you want to say these
lines in the exact order talk a little
bit and then say let's talk about this
hitter with the charm Halcyon is
changing and then I got no interest in
being a Lackey then you want to lie to
her face and then the next two speech
options are going to be the very top
options until the next speech check then
you hit her with some of that
temperament and then you're finished you
could tell her to get [ __ ] afterwards
if you want doesn't really matter but
you run down the hallway
grab her card do a little 360 as usual
and beat the outer world supernova
without eating drinking or sleeping and
honestly we did this in some good time
the food meter barely went down the
sleeper definitely gave us fatigue and
we were very very close to being fully
dehydrated hope you guys enjoyed this
video just as much as I had fun making
this this was actually a really pain in
the ass until I found out a few
alternatives like the helmet and using
le so this method does work and you will
get the supernovae achievement you of
course can get the other achievement for
driving yourself into the Sun if you
want to get that so think of us as a
guide as well is kind of a funny and
hopefully entertaining video be as
always like the view if you do enjoy
guys subscribe if you're new once again
thanks to char off with a little bit of
help on some of his videos a little bit
of tidbits of information I didn't know
about beforehand so yeah I think it to
him definitely go check his stuff out in
the description guys take care have a
girls today hopefully I'll see you in
the next video and peace out
[Music]